when patrice stallone became benin's
leader in 2016
he said he would remain in office only
for one term
but five years later here he is
voting for his second presidential term
after he voted tallon dismissed the
recent protests that broke out in parts
of the country
[Music]
security forces dealt with the problem
with tact the troublemakers were young
men and were unfortunately objects of
manipulation
our security forces overcame the
situation calmly
by this time tomorrow the healing
process begins
and we'll make sure such a situation
never arises again
ahead of sunday's vote security forces
are deployed in large numbers to
maintain
order nearly 5 million people have
registered to vote in the election
in 2019 less than a quarter of the
voting population
participated in the parliamentary
election that was won by the governing
party
in many polling stations like this only
a handful of voters stand up to cast
their ballots
others have stayed away because of
concerns about recent attacks
now election officials admit that the
protests have disrupted the supply of
election materials
in the mainly opposition stronghold of
the north
a weakened opposition has accused the
government of harassing and intimidating
its supporters
one of the candidates threatened to pull
out of the race two days before the
election
citing continuing harassment and
intimidation of the opposition by the
government
it is interesting for all the parties
taking part in this election
that the participation rate exceeds at
least 70 percent
elections are held so that citizens can
choose to choose means to vote
to vote means to choose who is entrusted
with the future of this country for the
next
five years i hope that victory will be
on our side because it is a sanctioned
vote that i invite
with the economy slowing down many
voters have high expectations of whoever
wins
i want to see the elected president
provide jobs and improve security
as it is it's too dangerous to go out at
night
tension is still high in some parts of
benin and election observers are calling
for calm
our urge to all of them appeal
is to continue the engagement
continue to ensure that the playing
field is level
continue to give opportunity to
everybody to participate
results are expected within 48 hours few
expect this vote to go into a second
round
which means president alone will likely
secure a second five-year mandate
that could strengthen his grip on power
ahmed idris
al jazeera kotino